welcome to another one of my doctors
other chalk and talk sessions where i
explore questions or issues comments
anything that's that's particularly
provocative and could use a blackboard
and being drawn out that come to me from
a variety of sources in this case uh
this is actually sort of a follow-up to
one of my earlier doctor similar shock
and talk videos
that had to do with should we teach
ethics in public schools should we teach
ethics you know k through 12 as well as
teaching ethics classes
in college
and the position that i took was yeah of
course we should be
because
you're learning ethics one way or the
other and either you're learning it well
or you're learning in a distorted sort
of way that's not going to help that
much it will leave you
vulnerable to manipulation
to
being caught moral quandaries to making
bad decisions that lead to other bad
decisions which due to dilemmas
there was quite a bit of discussion back
and forth
on
the comment section for that one
and one of the things that came up that
i thought was particularly interesting
was a suggestion was made
well i think that yeah you ought to
teach these these models of different
ethical
systems or moral theories however you
want to put it you've got to teach that
in schools but that's really kind of
static isn't it
don't you want to have something more
dynamic for the students like maybe
games theory right for those of you who
don't know what games theory is it's the
development of a particular branch of
mathematics
and it attempts to model strategic
decision making
and strategic decision making is where
you're not just
sort of optimizing
something within a process you're you're
trying to think about well what if that
other person over there who also affects
this process and who also has a stake in
it what if they go this way or this way
and try to predict what they might do
you also treat them as being rational
and you assume that they know that
you're rational so there's a lot of
abstractions involved in games theory
but it can be kind of fun to play around
with
and you can set up
some of the games that would be
interesting to teach people things
fairly easily like the prisoner's
dilemma
now
students do like that sort of thing
students always enjoy
exercises that get them engaged that get
them thinking that allow them to
interact a bit
but i think that it's a mistake
to assume that
because it works with models
and particularly since we work with text
and we present things in a somewhat
systematic way
that what we're doing in ethics is
actually kind of boring dry abstract
you know
not dynamic it's very static and the
students just kind of learn their thing
and then they go and apply it and so
what i want to do first is contrast and
so i've got this big schema up here i
want to contrast two different ways of
understanding the interaction that could
take place in a classroom two different
models of how theory works this doesn't
necessarily even have to be in a
classroom this could be in a lot of
other contexts as well think about
apprenticeship programs think about
teaching somebody how to cook think
about
teaching somebody martial arts
one common way of understanding
education
and you see this already being sort of
you know made fun of by plato
and socrates already back in ancient
greece is this notion that you sort of
you know the instructor has the
knowledge in their head and they just
kind of pour it into the
head of the student and now the student
can apply it
right so you have a transfer of
information
the instructor has the theory
whatever the body of theory consists in
the theory is basically static it's a
bunch of propositions
or you know maybe some skills or
something like that
um
they pass it on to the student god only
knows how there's a lot of different
ways to do that and then the students
you know the real test of whether they
understand it and can they apply it in
definite situations and all they're
doing then is sort of a mechanical
process
of applying the
static knowledge that they have in their
head and making it active and dynamic in
real life situations
okay that's the way a lot of people do
teach
i i had professors who taught like that
i have to admit that when i first
started teaching i'm willing to bet that
a lot of my teaching was like that too
you know exposition
of the material
here's the main points you know this is
what i want you to know and to memorize
okay that fits that
but
a lot of what goes on in ethics classes
whether we bring in games theory or
whether we design all sorts of other
exercises
is something a bit more like this i
think
to begin with we're always in the realm
of application
especially we're doing ethics
i mean
if you're doing ethics if you're talking
about ethics
and you explain plagiarism
you know for the paper in the class
is that just a matter of theory or is it
already a matter of application that's a
matter of application right that's a
real life situation
how students treat each other in the
class how people interact with
each other what to do with your
frustration when you don't understand
material
that's already no longer just a matter
of bare theory by itself but but theory
tied in with the application and quite
often for some ethical approaches some
moral theories
you don't actually develop the theory
without being involved in application
there's an iterative you know process
going back and forth back and forth you
can call it dialectical you can call it
iterative you can call it anything you
like point is theory and practice are
not so easily dissociable from each
other in certain ethical theories so
that means that if you're going to teach
those theories right
you probably can't just
pour the knowledge out there for those
students and say ah there you go you
know for instance virtue ethics
if you're going to teach virtue ethics
well there has to be some component of
you actually
engaging in it
but we'll get to that in a moment so
with this sort of thing the the
instructor would show up and the
instructor actually has embodied the
theory of the instructor has you know it
available to them
then they put it in the center and now
the students engage around it and this
can this can be done in a lot of
different ways it doesn't necessarily
have to be through games
or group activities or things like that
that can be done through classroom
discussions
where you put something on the table and
you actually instead of just in a
lecture you can have lecture discussion
talk for a little bit what do you think
about that can you think of any examples
of that are those good examples
already when you're doing that you are
taking the theory and putting it in the
center of those students you're not just
lining them all up in their their neat
desks and
laying the knowledge out there and
hoping some of them pick it up you know
like like fish they bite on and put the
hook
instead if we want to continue the fish
metaphor you're trying to to encourage
something like a feeding frenzy
i don't know how much you know about
fish but one thing that fish do is they
they exhibit what's called memetic
desire which means that a fish
the desire that it has will often be
triggered by seeing another fish getting
something so fish season other fish
eating and then it says i think i'd like
to eat too
we do this as human beings
works really great in bars you know
people one person lights up a cigarette
not everybody who's a smoker feels like
they have a smoke right well it works
the same way with knowledge too
if you can get people engaged if you can
get them
interested if you can get them
passionate
you get one student you know talking
about things you might be able to get
the rest of them
interested in talking about it
especially if you can tie it in
constantly with applications how does
this fit into your life that's one of
the things i do constantly
in my ethics classes i try to connect
the material to where my students are
and that produces dynamic learning
and i'm doing that
not by
you might say dumbing it down or
by
skipping through the tough stuff and
just going to the fun things you know
the sexy you know sayings or things like
that
we're doing the
the material but we're doing it in a
dynamic way
and
i think there's a lot of professors out
there actually doing that i know that i
had some i didn't really think of it in
those terms but i had some who were
doing that in their classes while i was
in their classes some of them
in elementary school some in high school
some in
college some in graduate school
so what i want to say before we move on
to the other stuff it's quite possible
to have a model in which
moral theories or models are not just
static information thrown out there
which then has to be livened up by some
sort of you know
bells and whistles
if you're teaching the moral theory well
as a teacher doing what you ought to be
doing
you're not just presenting content
and you don't necessarily have to have
lesson plans to do this good teachers
can do this on the spot with students
they can meet them where they are
you want to make it something that
everybody is
or at least enough of the students at
critical mass are involved with and
which ties in with their concerns in
their life
so now let's think about some
that's the point that i was making here
if they're taught well moral theories by
themselves are dynamic
i mean there's a reason why people have
been reading plato
in the republic
and all these other dialogues and
reading aristotle's what are essentially
lecture notes
for generation after generation after
generation it's not just because we like
classic words it's because
if you actually
work your way through them and you know
how to read those sort of texts
they are incredibly
dynamic text they represent a clash of
perspectives over and over and over
again
there's conflict in them there's you
might say even narrative not just
talking about plato in his dialogues
there's narrative even in aristotle
the clash of different viewpoints on
things and this person could say this
and this person could say that
if you can actually get into that
then
they become very dynamic now the trouble
is how do you get this across the
students that's you know
like i said if you can read them that
way but we shouldn't we shouldn't just
automatically assume that students are
going to read them that way there's a
lot of obstacles to that and so we have
to do the work as instructors to make
that possible which means first off we
have to know that material inside and
out and we have to be passionate about
it and care about it there's not an
awful lot of point in trying to teach
something and make a dynamic if you
yourself don't care about it
luckily i think most most people who
teach this stuff actually do
what are some examples of things that
by their very nature if you're teaching
them
with students who are at least
you know engaged to some degree
are going to be
interesting dynamic
um you can build all sorts of all sorts
of work around them all sorts of lessons
around it well i'll think about
utilitarianism
carrying out a utilitarian calculation
of any given scenario that you want to
put in front of students
seeing how they carry it
or seeing how they would carry out and
whether they do carry out utilitarian
calculations
in their day-to-day life
in deciding whether to go home for
christmas or not
deciding whether to take this class or
that class
pick topics that are kind of sticky and
messy where you can actually have
students make
partly right
answers partly right choices and then
partly wrong and then you can you can
build off of that and say well because
with utilitarian calculations one way
people go partly wrong is by not
including everybody whose
pleasures and pains are
affected by it right utilitarian
calculations are about pleasures and
pains
everybody's concerned
so
you start out by by putting a situation
in front of them they get you know the
idea that some people are affected this
way some people are affected this way
now you widen them
you expand the time frame you say what
about these people what about these
people that's dynamic
that shows them the process of change
right there as you're teaching it
even value clarification a lot of people
doing ethics won't say value
clarification that's that's just garbage
because basically what value
clarification is figuring out what do
you want and it stops there
well you know actually figuring out what
you do in fact desire
that takes some work and a lot of people
think that they want certain things and
it turns out that some of them they
don't actually want them when they get
them because they wanted something else
that came with it that or they thought
came with it and sometimes our deeper
desires are a bit buried and have to be
brought to life
you can do all sorts of exercises with
this and you can reflect on it and you
can have students compare and contrast
theirs to each other why do you feel
that way why why do you value this why
don't you value that
applying the categorical imperative
these are the first two formulations of
it which are
usually about as far as you get in an
ethics class because the third one is
kind of kind of tricky
being able to apply the criterion of can
you universalize this action
now there's more to the categorical
imperative than that i know but
that's a good starting point or
by doing this sort of action would you
be treating somebody as a means to an
end
getting students to think about that to
look at determinate situations also to
look at their own lives are you using
people as a means to an end
what about i always use this as an
example what about me and teaching you
i'm getting paid to teach you aren't i
just using you as a means
already you're in a very dynamic
conversation by doing that
when it comes to virtue ethics
figuring out whether an action or a
person is actually virtuous or vicious
or something in between perhaps
you know self-control lack of
self-control
doing actions for which they're not
entirely responsible
on the way to being virtuous on the way
to being vicious in accordance with
advice and importance of virtue
all these sorts of things figuring out
those the nitty-gritty of it
actually looking at cases and saying
look is this person is this person a
good person do they have good traits
what are they
how do you define those traits what did
aerosols say about those traits what do
augustine say about those traits
do you buy what they're saying
do you think they left something out
which of these do you think is is most
important in evaluating the goodness or
badness of the person or the reactions
who do we take as models already
you notice there's the questions just
come spilling out
very dangerous
working out norms by agreement this
would be something along the lines of
doing games theory right
contracturian ethics
and some other
forms of ethics discourse ethics
have to do with
working out norms by actually like
sitting down with people and saying
well um can we all get on board with
this
and you know somebody something makes an
objection and somebody else says
there's
good reasons for doing things this way
that's dynamic you get students talking
you get them engaged you get them
thinking
you can do that again with the classroom
you can apply this to their their own
lives as students you can apply this to
their work lives you can apply it to
their family lives
discovering the value of the person or
of a relationship
here we you know might be doing virtue
ethics we might be doing ethics of care
we might be doing personalist ethics
various sorts
um
thinking about
the people who we actually do love or
are the people that we hate what is it
that we love about them
are they just those qualities or
reactions or consequences that mean love
where is there something
beyond that is there value in the
relationship
beyond just that of the two or more
people involved in the relationship
and again you have tons of stuff you can
play off with students
you can get them talking about their own
families and comparing them to each
other you can always get them talking
about romantic relationships what's
going on with those
they're quite often quite happy to
disclose
finally you know one of the things
that's going to be going on with all of
this is exploring
and trying to figure out what's the
proper ordering of different
goods or bad things in relation to each
other that's something that ethics is
intimately concerned with
i think all of this could be taught to
high school and to middle school
students
and you know it doesn't have to be
taught necessarily by making them read
aristotle and kant and mill
but i also think that that couldn't hurt
either
the last thing i want to say
has to do with moral theories i said
moral theories by themselves are dynamic
very often that gets sort of covered up
by the way in which we present it with
this theory of education where it's just
packets of information that we pass on
to each other
but normal theories that they're
properly understood are extremely
dynamic because they have to do with
people's lives how they shape them how
they make decisions how they progress
towards their good what their good
actually is
how they judge things and what i want to
say is theories are exemplified they are
embodied and they are endorsed by
living human beings who we can point to
and who actually get into dialogue with
each other so moral theories
in fact come into dialogue with each
other
in our day-to-day situations again it's
like this
the theories we could put several
different theories here
give them a situation
this sort of thing happens
can we evaluate this from three
different perspectives a virtue ethics
perspective a deontological perspective
and a utilitarian perspective that's
already asking quite a bit but you get
the point
how would these theories respond to each
other in this case
because they do respond to each other
well that's growth to learn that sort of
thing
so
uh
very thankful for that that comment and
that suggestion that was given to me in
my other doctor's other chalk and talk
about should ethics be taught in school
this is a follow-up from that you might
say this is a bit of
of
cheerleading
for
how ethics could be taught dynamically
in school and why it wants to be taught
in that way